[Music]
[Applause]
I think Selena's legacy has a it's gonna
stretch for a while longer I just want
to thank the fans so much selena
constantly surprises not only myself but
her family and just to turn out of the
fans and the energy that they bring are
going nuts
selena quintanilla receives her star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame
[Applause]
why is selena your queen everything her
style her hair everything everything she
was just amazing anyone's hurt being
gone she still changes so many lives
actress Eva Longoria got emotional
paying tribute to the late Tejano star
beyond humbling to stand here on behalf
of a person who I myself owe so much to
I'm not gonna cry Selena's sister
Suzette accepted the honor on the
family's behalf Selena said the goal
isn't to live forever but to create
something that will and I think tonight
is a perfect testament of that today was
such an emotional special day what does
it mean to you to see your daughter be
honored I'm very proud just hearing
everybody sweet and such and just
positive empowering words from very
powerful people it was just emotional
for me I just loved watching it sounds
great is it emotional for you yeah yeah
you can't I can't help it you know but
it's also a source of strength to see
the impact that she had on so many
different generations of people so you
know it's it's bittersweet
it's the best way I think I could
describe it it's um you know we miss her
we all miss her um but yet to see the
impact that she had on everybody it's
just incredible she's shattering records
she's still charting mine 23 years later
and to me the biggest thing is I have my
dreams were one
dan wanted to see her t-shirts next to
Marilyn Monroe's she's at all the stores
now and it's great seeing that there are
times when it feels like you can pick up
the phone and call her you know or
you're gonna drive home and she's gonna
be there and then there's the moments
that you know it can be difficult it's
it catches me off guard like if I'm at a
restaurant or something and you know
we're having dinner and then they're
playing music and then all of a sudden
it's her song that comes on and then
it's like when I'm not prepared for it
that can be a little hard today I was
happy because my mom we all held strong
you know I'm saying it was happy of it I
can't when I came I was in my room I
kind of got a knot in my throat because
I can from my room I can see the Capitol
Tower and I just was like man this is
just gonna be too overwhelming you know
but it was more for me of a proud moment
it was a proud moment I was I was a
proud brother if you had the opportunity
to say something to her today
what would you say just that I'm you
know I'm proud of her I'm proud of
everything that she has been able to
accomplish I'll miss her always miss her
every day
[Music]